we learned in the videos on torque
that torque
it equals
let me let me actually draw a picture so
you remember what we're talking about
with torque so let's say
so that's the arm
let's say right here is kind of what its
pivot is
that's its pivot
and let's say that i'm i'm putting a
a force
attempting a force
a force right there and it's
perpendicular to this arm and let's say
the length of this arm is
r
and this
force is
well it's let's say that
let's say that this force is f
so we know that the for the torque is
this force times the distance
right torque is
force
times
a distance
and then we also know
that what is force well that is equal to
mass times acceleration times distance
so torque is equal to mass times
acceleration times distance
and then so so what is and then what is
acceleration well that's equal to mass
times change in velocity over change in
time
times distance
right
so that we learned all that from our
torque chapter and you might want to
review it just to get an intuition of of
what torque is good for but in general
if something isn't spinning you apply a
torque and you'll get it spinning or if
something is spinning already if you
apply torque in the direction that it's
spinning it'll spin faster or if you go
in the opposite direction it'll spin
slower
and and what i'm showing you here is
that
what happens if you apply no torque well
if you apply no torque then we know that
this quantity
is zero or another another way to think
about it actually why did i write d this
is well it couldn't be d but i shouldn't
call this r this should be d
so if this is zero if if we're applying
no torque right what do we know we know
the change in velocity over change in
time times this distance won't change
that this this quantity is zero so we
know that
the velocity
times the distance
is going to be a constant
and that comes from what i just you know
talked about it i sometimes almost feel
like it it is it falls out of newton's
laws but it applies to spinning an
object that's not spinning will tend to
not stay spinning and an object that is
spinning will tend to stay spinning
so in this case if this object at this
point right here so we're in a case
where there's no torque so this force is
zero there's no force applying here and
whatever this object's velocity was
right is tangential
velocity it's going to stay that
velocity
right it's just going to keep spinning
at that velocity if i apply more torque
and it'll go even faster if i apply less
torque it'll it it'll slow down a little
bit
but we know that this velocity times the
distance is constant and actually i
don't know why i took this m out we know
that the mass times the velocity times
the distance is constant
right
so what does that tell us well we
learned in the
in the um
in the
angular velocity video my mind's a
little slow today that what angular
velocity is equal to velocity divided by
divided by the radius and in this case
the radius is this distance so we could
also write it as velocity over distance
and when i talk about radius it's just
the radius of the circle that you're
kind of going spinning around in right
if that was this could be the circle up
here so this d that's the same thing as
the radius i'm just switching letters to
confuse you but let's see if we can if
we can if we can write something if we
can change this expression to include
angular velocity and you'll see where
i'm going in a second
so let's solve for v so let's multiply
both sides of this times d
so you get dw is equal to v right i just
took this d put it on this side
so let's write that here m
times
d
w
right i just replaced the v
times d is equal to a constant assuming
that we have no net torque on the system
and so what does that get us well that
gets us m
times the angular velocity times d
squared
is equal to a constant
so what does this tell us this tells us
the mass of an object spinning so let me
let me rewrite this because i think
invert
so what we know is that the mass of of
an object spinning
times
how fast it is spinning
the the distance to the the center of
its rotation and actually i'm going to
change that d to an r i don't know why i
even use d to begin with
times that squared that's going to be
equal to a constant
assuming no net force no net torque and
another way of of looking at that if we
if we just wanted to go to angular
velocity from the get go we could have
said torque
is equal to mass
times
change in velocity times change in time
times the radius to the the center of
where you're rotating around
and change in velocity is just the same
thing as
mass
times
change in
angular velocity
times r
change in time and then there's another
r that's this r right because velocity
is angular velocity times r and we're
assuming r doesn't change so any change
in velocity is just going to be a change
in the angular velocity
and then we would get the same thing
that we just got here if we have no net
torque we're going to have no change in
angular velocity so angular velocity
will be a constant so you'll get mass
times angular velocity times and then
you have this r and this r
times r squared is going to be equal a
constant
what am i where am i going with all of
this well let's let's think about
something
let's say
that i have some object traveling in a
circle
i do everything for a reason and you'll
see my reason right now
let's say
let's say that this is some some kind of
well let me i think it'll make sense in
a second
so this is
i don't know let's say this is some type
of retractable pole
and i'm an ice skater
and i'm not using the ice skater's body
right now for for uh because it'll
become complicated let's say this is
some type of robot arm
right and that's its joint right there
and it's holding a mass out here
it's holding a mass
and this is neat because after this this
concept you will understand what goes on
in figure skating and in the olympics oh
no the winter olympics are over aren't
they well anyway um so let's say that
this object is is spinning around at
some rate right
some rate
uh let's say it's spinning around at oh
i don't know 10 10 radians a second
radians a second that's its angular
velocity
and let's say right now it's its
rotational distance
is i don't know let's say it's
it's 10 feet
so let's say this is you know this is
spinning on a on a uh
this is an object that's spinning on an
ice skating rink i guess is a good way
because you don't want friction all of
that so what's its its current
angular momentum so that's what this
this term right here is angular momentum
so what's this and current angular
momentum
well it's its mass
times 10
times right
10 is its actually let me let's make
this raise a different number let's
let's call it let's call it 8 feet just
so you know what i'm doing so it's
angular velocity is 10
and then its radius is 8 so times 64. so
it equals 640 times the mass this is its
angular momentum
right
now what happens if this arm for
whatever reason shortens and you know
maybe it does something like this
the arm kind of bends and then the mass
comes here it comes in closer to the
center let me write that in a different
color
the mass comes close to the center so
now the radius is four but i've had no
net torque on the system all i've done
is change is change how far it is from
the center of rotation
how much faster is it going to spin now
well let's think about it its angular
momentum won't change this is a constant
which is its angular momentum
that won't change so we now know that
the mass
times
times the angular the new angular
momentum we'll write that the angle
momentum one
times the new distance squared times 16
is also going to be equal to 640
m right the angular momentum doesn't
change let's cross out m from both sides
and then divide both sides by 16. we now
have that w1 is equal to 16 goes into
640.
so what happened originally i was going
around at 10 radians per second when i
halved the radius when i got
when i got half as close to the center
of my rotation i'm actually spinning
around four times as much and that's
because this term
is a quadratic term and and this makes
uh
you probably have observed this behavior
before when you have when you see the
ice skater skating around and and
they're spinning with their arms wide
open and then they pull their arms in
and they go a lot lot faster and that's
because the their angular velocity or
the rate at which they're spinning is
proportional to the square
of of the radius around their their axis
of rotation anyway i hope i didn't
confuse you and i'll do some more
problems with this in the future but
i've just run out of time see you soon